good morning Maureen Johnson good
morning nerdfighters and good morning
John Green if you were watching this it
is January 20 freaking 5th I can't
believe that so much time has it time
goes way faster when you get older have
I talked about the logarithmic aid scale
yet I have I talked about it very
briefly in the vegetarianism video
basically I believe that you should have
many birthdays when you are young
because more stuff happens when you're
young then when you're old when you're
old you don't want to celebrate
birthdays every year and when you're
young you want to have one every week
the problem is figuring out which
logarithmic coefficient exactly we
should use and also that no one would
ever buy into it but maybe maybe if we
work on it really hard like there's not
other more important stuff to work on
really hard but anyway that has nothing
to do with what I wanted to talk about
today so that was the first segment of
this video stuff that I didn't mean to
talk about and here is the second
segment of the video news reports from
John I just talked to John he's doing
very well they have decided to keep
Henry John was literally changing a
diaper when I called him that sort of
hit home to me like yeah
you're really a dad now you're changing
a diaper more news from Henry is that
Henry currently has the hiccups
so that's adorable and John and Sarah
are both very tired now I'm gonna toss
it over to Hank for news about his puppy
Thank You Hank much appreciated that's
right I got a dog kind of Catherine and
I are fostering a greyhound that didn't
work out in another home there are a
couple of issues with the dog one we
can't figure out what to call it because
it has no name greyhounds because they
spend their early lives as working dogs
don't get called ever so if you make
like adorable noises like look at me and
maybe chameleon they'll come to you but
this dog doesn't have a name and I don't
want to call them any mimimi but we
don't know what to call it it's a girl
and she's eight years old and she's
really adorable and very nice and the
only reason that I might not keep this
dog is because there's one member of our
family who gets 10 million votes and out
votes everyone when making family pet
decisions in that member of the family
is cameo and right now cameos vote is
firmly against the dog we're trying to
persuade her but additionally the dog
kind of doesn't like cameo very much or
possibly likes cameo too much it's worth
noting that greyhounds are bred
specifically to
Chace fluffy things so break gray homes
are often very focused on on fluffy
things and we really don't want to be
focused on kitties fluffy tail so if
they can learn to be friends then we're
definitely going to keep the dog in any
case we want something to call it
because we're fostering it for the next
week or so while they're working on
making room for her at the Greyhound
farm and finally since we're talking
about dogs already I'm gonna kick it
over to Hank from last week and he's
gonna start you off on an episode of
truth or fail about dogs Maureen I will
see you on Wednesday
my name is Hank green and my brother
just had a baby and all this talk about
John Green's baby is making me think
about you know possibly taking the next
step in my life so me and my wife have
been talking a lot about making our two
into three I'm talking of course about
getting a dog and as I've been reading
up on these marvelous creatures I've
found out many fascinating facts and now
I'm gonna tell you some of those facts
but some of them are gonna be lies every
round you get two facts all you have to
do is click on the true one or you fail
let's go
anybody anybody know that's from leave
it in a comment if you know what that's
problem fact number one Chewbacca
hamsa ever-present arm tearing out of
the sockets sidekick cat vocalizations
that were based on those of an Alaskan
Malamute or fact to all dogs because
their brains are much less complicated
than ours are ambidextrous favoring
neither their right nor their left paw